HéHélène Buzzetti, Paul Journet
PaPaul Wells.
BoBonsoir à vous tous.
- - (ensemble) bonsoir.
- - On se de très affectif là-
dededans. Quand on regarde l'eft
susur la popularité des
didirigeants, sur la popularité
dede, un sondage qui indique ça
jojoue en faveur de Monsieur
JuJustin Trudeau. Certains portt
dedes gens le soutiennent dans a
gegestion. 53 % le voient commen
bobon leader. Hélène, réaction..
- - C'est très passager ce genre
dede sondage. C'est totalement
réréjouissant pour un leader, ne
veveut pas être durable. Sans
vovouloir être cynique, c'est ts
frfréquent que des crises commea
etet pour effet de ramener des
opopinions publiques derrière le
leleader. Le Baddock à long tere
vava tout lui pardonner.
PoPour l'instant, Monsieur Trudu
lului permet de faire oublier un
cecertain nombre de choses. Cete
loloi sur les mesures d'urgence
ququi avait été adoptée et
ababandonnée pour mater la
ququestion de cammionneurs. On
n'n'en parle plus du tout. Il ya
unun débat le Chambre des commus
auaujourd'hui. Ça permet comme a
d'd'évacuer les sujets agréable,
mamais à long terme, ça peut
rerevenir. Peut avoir des effets
nénéfastes de cette crise pour
MoMonsieur Trudeau.
- - Parce que sa gestion décrive
dedes cammionneurs était perçue
trtrès différemment par la
popopulation.
- - Oui. La question essentiell,
lolors du convoi des soi-disant
cacammionneurs, Monsieur Trudeaa
étété très largement de l'opinin
pupublique. La vaccination,
coconfinement était très souten.
EtEt donc, ce serait intéressant
dede voir ci-après le convoi des
sosoi-disant cammionneurs, après
leles faits de ralliement des
mimigraines un effet sur les
inintentions de vote. Ce n'est s
totout à fait la même chose quee
vovoir ces gens appuie de façon
gégénérale la position du Canada
ququi est identique opposition e
totous les gouvernements du mon.
LaLa question de savoir s'il y a
plplus de monde qui vont voter
lilibéral. Là, je ne suis pas
cecertain. J'ai l'impression que
lele voter libéral plafonne deps
dédéjà trois ans. Ce n'est pas e
guguerre en Europe qui va changr
cecela du jour au lendemain.
- - Reste que sur le plan de la
peperception, le type de
leleadership est très différent.
OnOn avait l'impression d'une
esespèce d'inertie équipée de
gogouvernement qui dit ce n'est
papas dans ma cour. Ça appartiet
avavec l'avis d'Ottawa. Alors qe
llà, le grondement est très
prprésent. Mme Freeland lead
bebeaucoup de crises avec
l'l'Ukraine.
- - Avoir une qui parle la lange
nene nuit pas. Ce qui profite
grgrandement Trudeau c'est surtt
ququ'il n'y a pas de contraste
mamarqué e entre ce que les libx
fofont ce que les oppositions
prproposent. Notamment parce que
leles recours du Canada dans un
tetel conflit sont assez limité.
SiSi vous regardez les débats, l
n'n'y a pas de grande fracture
ididéologique cadre intervention
quque le Canada devrait faire. n
cece sens, c'est le seul sujet i
ococcupe auprès de l'actuelle
c'c'est la régression russe en
UkUkraine inscrit grandement
TrTrudeau ressemble un peu à ce
quque les oppositions voudraien,
nonormal qu'il y ait un appui à
MoMonsieur Trudeau. Cela dit, ds
leles sondages il y a deux choss
ququ'on peut regarder. Les grans
tetendances de fond et les
flfluctuations. Les fluctuation,
çaça peut attirer votre attenti.
CeCe sont des vagues passagères.
JeJe ne sais pas où en sera le
coconflit, mais je doute qu'on
sosoit dans les tendances de fod
avavec ça. C'est plus tôt un
épépiphénomène du point de vu de
lala politique canadienne.
- - Information curieuse déterre
papar notre collègue. On se
rarappelle tous du couvre-feu
imimposé à la fin décembre. On
nonous apprend que ces heures
avavant le point de presse où on
anannonçait l'imposition du
cocouvre-feu, Monsieur Arruda,
didirecteur de la force publiqu,
chcherchait une justification
scscientifique pour être capable
dede répondre aux questions des
jojournalistes et il n'en a pas
trtrouvé. Il a fait appel aux
exexperts, il n'en a pas trouvé.
QuQu'est-ce que ça vous dit
fifinalement sur cette idée
d'd'imposer un couvre-feu.
- - D'abord, on s'en doutait qul
n'n'y avait pas de justification
auaudacieuse et scientifique,
sisinon nous leur est offerte iy
a a longtemps. Ça vienne comme e
imimpression qu'on avait sur
MoMonsieur Arruda. Il jouait
bebeaucoup un rôle politique, et
dadans le cas qui nous occupe,
cecelui de deuxième couvre-feu,a
popolitique a commandé ce couvr-
fefeu, et on a ensuite cherché e
jujustification scientifique sur
lalaquelle appuyer ce couvre-fe.
CeCe n'était pas sincèrement cea
lele rôle de Monsieur Arruda. Ça
vivient confirmer une impression
ququ'on avait Monsieur Arruda qi
sese retrouvait un peu trop dans
l'l'équipe politique. Ceci dit,e
dedemeure convaincu que ce couv-
fefeu a été proposé la dernière
miminute devant les chiffres
afaffolants de totalisation et i
ététait surtout pour éviter les
paparties de jour de l'an. On au
pepeur cette défaite et on a
trtrouvé que le couvre-feu était
lala façon la plus rapide de les
emempêcher s'est fait pendant la
pépériode habituelle de congés s
cicitoyens. C'est pour ça qu'ony
a a eu recours. Je pense que ça
étété comme ça raccourci qu'on a
prpris parce que c'était plus
fafacile.
- - On a bien fait, l'effet sura
CACAQ. Ça va passer auprès de la
popopulation. Il n'y a pas un
gogouvernement qui n'est contrat
d'd'imposer un couvre-feu.
PoPourquoi ne pas dire la vérité
auaux gens?
écécoutait, les parties on ne pt
papas le faire. Ne fera pas
cocouvre-feu, on va vous expliqr
sisimplement. La question de la
trtransparence, c'est ça.
- - Si on avait procédé comme ç,
jeje ne pense pas que c'est une
ququestion honnête odysée, est-e
ququ'on y va avec la carotte oue
bbâton, recommandation la
cocoercition. Il y a eu de couv-
fefeu. Le premier, ça été bien
dodocumenté, n'était pas une
susuggestion du gouvernement
LeLegault. Ça avait été suggéré
papar la santé publique, plus
prprécisément par le docteur Ér.
LeLe gouvernement Legault avait
acaccepté à reculons. Elle devat
hésisiter pendant une journée. e
n'n'était pas une décision
popolitique dans un premier tem.
EnEntre autres parce que aucun
gogouvernement ne va profiter
popolitiquement. Le deuxième
cocouvre-feu, il y a eu un
raraisonnement dont celui dont
paparle Hélène, on était débord,
nene sait plus comment convaince
leles gens de ne pas se rassembr
chchez eux et on a ressorti cel.
PoPour revenir à la question dea
vivie scientifique, les études i
sesemblent établir un lien causl
momontrent que ça pouvait faire
paparti des outils non
phpharmacologiques, intervention
plplus sociale des politiques
pupubliques. Il y en a. On n'est
papas capable de démontrer un ln
cacausal ni peut-être même une
rerelation forte. Il y a un lien
téténu. La grande question, je
trtrouve, pourquoi est-ce qu'on
rerefuse, pourquoi le document e
vovotre collègue Thomas Gervais
ququ'il a demandé a été calvaire
des s points il n'y a pas de
jujustification pour ça.
- - C'est la vie demandée par
ArArruda en catastrophe.
- - On aurait pu trouver des
jujustifications scientifiques.
CeCes méthodes que Arruda n'est
papas été capable de les trouver
lului-même. Quelle bardait un
dodocument est prise par les ges
dede l'administration publique i
ggère le demande accès à
l'l'information. Je me rends trs
mamal à l'aise de ce genre de
mamanque de transparence.
- - Paul, quand on compare les
memesures prises à Québec, on
apapparaisse dans les autres
prprovinces. On est en train de
dédéconfine et oQuébec. On est n
trtrain d'avancer. On est en trn
d'd'avancer l'agenda. Essaie dea
vivitesse. Si on se compare avec
lele reste du Canada, on reste
dadans les provinces ou maintiet
lele plus longtemps les mesures
cocomme le masque le passeport
vavaccinal aussi. C'est quand me
cucurieux de voir à quel point
auautres sont débarrassés de ces
memesures unitaires.
- - Oui. Ne pas dire que les
auautres en raison est que le
QuQuébec a tort. Chaque province
leles outils qu'il choisit en
fofonction de la séance et des
prpressions éthiques. Chacun prd
unun pari. C'était un peu étonné
dede voir lors du discours du
prprésident Biden Le Congrès hir
sosoir quelques jours à peine
ququ'on est rendue obligatoire e
poport du masque, il est presque
pepersonne dans une salle. C'est
unun arricomprend. Certains qu'l
auaura plus de cas. C'est certan
ququ'il n'y aura pas autant de
tototalisation, mais une légère
reremontée. Chaque gouvernement
titire ses choix en fonction de
çaça. Ce qui est malsain, je sus
d'd'accord avec mes collègues,
c'c'est la soupe politique
scscientifique dans laquelle
babaigne tous les gouvernements
dedepuis deux ans. Chaque
gogouvernement présent, ces
exexperts scientifiques
trtravaillent pour le gouvernemt
cocomme bouclier. Ce n'est pas n
chchoix, c'est la science qui
didicte les difficiles démarches
ququ'on est obligé d'entreprend.
AlAlors que chacun sait ou devrt
sasavoir que la science ne donne
papas de solution. Elle donne ds
coconsignes, des probabilités et
enen fonction de ça, les
gogouvernements choisissent. C't
çaça qu'on réapprend avec cette
hihistoire de l'Arruda.
- - Parlons maintenant de Jean
ChCharest. Il invite les
coconsommateurs à le rencontrer.
IlIl est à Ottawa dans le centr-
viville. N'a pas été rendu publ.
L'L'invitation est lancée à tou:
ququelques conservateurs ont
acaccepté de réagir.
- - La petite fête avec Monsieur
ChCharest, ce soir?
- - Non, malheureusement,
j'j'ai une autre réunion.
- - Allez-vous voir Monsieur
ChCharest, ce soir?
- - Oui!
- - Pourquoi?
- - Hein? Parce que
c'c'est un excellent candidat.
- - Allez-vous être là?
- - On a des votes à la chambre,
onon va regarder ce qu'on
pepeut faire.
- - Mais donc, c'est un oui
ouou un non, Monsieur Charest?
- - Ah, j'ai pas regardé
momon agenda.
(i(inaudible)
BoBonne journée!
- - Bon, Paul, je vais commencer
avavec vous. Pensez-vous que les
gegens vont être nombreux d'allr
acaccepter l'invitation de Jean
ChCharest. Devrait-il avoir de
nonombreuses questions à lui
poposer.
- - Pour plusieurs personnes, ne
sesera que de la courtoisie.
MoMonsieur Charest connaît bien
leles députés conservateurs.
SuSurtout les Québécois. Je l'ai
sosouvent vu dans des événements
ququand Stephen Harper de premir
miministre et lui premier minise
dudu Québec. Je l'ai vu avec pln
dede députés conservateurs de
l'l'époque. Mais il polarise le
cacaucus comme le parti. Ce sont
plplutôt de tendance progressise
coconservateur accueillent plutt
bibien sa candidature. Ceux qui
sosont plus tôt Trumpiste,
bebeaucoup moins.
- - Hélène, il y a sûrement des
gegens qui vont vérifier jusqu'à
ququelle point Monsieur Charest
esest encore conservateur. Quel
gegenre de conservateurs?
- - progressiste conservateur.
C'C'est peut-être un tout autre
paparti. Est-ce que vous avez ft
jojouer, quelqu'un a dit, je n'i
papas converti mon agenda. J'éts
lala aujourd'hui c'est entre dex
cacaucus : on a posé la questioà
totout le monde et cette réponse
ététait visiblement une ligne
écécrite préparée d'avance.
PlPlusieurs députés nous l'ont
fofourni.
- - Ils ne veulent pas dévoiler
leleur jeu.
- - Ça, en soi, je trouve ça
rérévélateur. De dire qu'on est
ggênée de rencontrer un ancien
chchef de notre ancien parti
popolitique. Démontre à quel pot
c'c'est un personnage dans le
cocontexte de ce nouveau parti
coconservateur qui est un peu
clclivant, qui ne fait pas
l'l'affaire de tout le monde. On
esest un petit peu gêné de se
prprésenter. Ceci dit, je
mementionne pas les doit à l'hee
dede la loi sur les mesures
d'd'urgence vers l'objet de
cocomités. Ce soir va y avoir un
vovote. Il doit y avoir un vote
8h8h30. Va peut-être nuire à la
ffête. Il faut se garder à
l'l'esprit que même s'il devaity
avavoir beaucoup de monde ce so,
leles députés ne représentent
ququ'un seul vote chacun.
VoVous pouvez avoir beaucoup de
dédéputés derrière vous, ne vous
gagarantit pas le succès.
- - Mais ça aide quand même à
prpréparer sa sortie publique,
dédévoilée, je me présente, j'ai
dedes appuis, il m'entoure
auaujourd'hui.
- - Surtout pour Monsieur Chare,
paparce que Monsieur Charest ne
papartira pas d'aussi loin en
ararrière et voudrait avoir une
rereprésentativité géographique
miminimale. Je te présente
seseulement avec des députés
ququébécois derrière lui.
NeNe suffira pas les dépeindre n
grgrand rassembleur. Ça, flagrat
dédélit de Monsieur Charest. C't
ququand même étonnant qu'il n'et
papas une plus grande audience e
seserait-ce que par curiosité. e
nene sais pas à quel point il ya
bebeaucoup de choses à faire à
OtOttawa en début mars : il y a
plplusieurs questions que ce poe
susur ses positions. Les plusies
ququestions qui réclament le
reretour de Jean Charest, mais n
n'n'est pas capable de dire quee
poposition il va dépendre à part
ququ'on résume sera entre cellee
nonotre dos de Pierre Poilièvre.
- - A de voir le jour où il va e
prprésenter, s'il le fait. Commt
évévaluer justifier. Comment va-
ilil se présenter: en sauveur?
ilil y a beaucoup de questions.n
atattend cette annonce qui se
dédéplace. Merci d'avoir été avc
nonous ce soir.
-(-(Ensemble): au revo